THE BOSTON BRUINS THREW
EVERYTHING HIS
CHABOT BACK TO THE BLUE
LINE.
WATCH THIS.
YOU CAN HARDLY SEE IT. YOU GIVEO
ONE ANOTHER.
YOU COME UP AND ON.
FORMENTON WILL KNOCK IT AROUND
VAN RIEMSDYK. GOAL .
CLOSING IN, SIOBHAN THE FEED,
SHORTHANDED SITUATION.
>> Craig: HERE IS THE LAST NHL.
SCHULTZ INSIDE.
MURRAY ON WILSONMAKING ITS
MOBILE TOUR THROUGHOUT
MANEUVERS BACK TO CENTER WIT TH
BEHIND HIM.
OVI .
KUZY GOT ALL OF IT.
SIZZLE.
ILYA SAMSONOV ORD.
YOU WILL SEE THE STEP ON
CHOLOWSKI  COMING OFF
SHEARY TRIES IT AGAIN.
ONCE HIS WAY OUT OF THE
CORNER.
CHOLOWSKI TOWARD THE
INTO THE CORNER.
HOLDEN IS THE FIRST ONE ON I OV
THE GLASS.
WILSON CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
KUZNETSOV
>> Craig: HAGELIN ANDS
CAMPAIGN.
POINTS IN 6 OF 8.
LOST 6E OF
FREEZING THE P
FIVE SHOTS ON NET.
NOTICE WHERE THEY ALL COME FROM.
ALL
THERE IS KEMPNY. ALONG SLAPPER
HALF WALL.
VAN RIEMSDYK, CRISSCROSSING. TV
THAT ALLOWS  OVECHKIN TO
SAVED  A GOOD STOP BY
VANECEK.
MAN ADVANTAGE FOR ANOTHER 65
SECONDS.E LOOKED LIKE THAT WHEN
IN.
THE REFEREE AT THE TOP OF IT.
THERE IS.
IT HITS THE BAR.
PONSE WITH CHABOT